quel est votre nom notamment de sydney
maquette c'est un nom très célèbre mais
alors où il y au faz puis-je savoir que
votre père john mchale et à londres en
angleterre
il fait quoi il est commandant en chef
des forces navales américaines pour
l'europe à rosario
là j'avais 31 walk of fame
d'où venez vous jacksonville en floride
ma famille habite à hayon mérite y êtes
vous mariée elle utile et vous des
enfants
ces trois balles de 5 2 en co lyonnais
même vous pouvez vous les nommez ta
bosse et monétaires dans quelle unité
servier vous sur une 163e bataillon
d'attac sur le porte avions au risque
année alors combien de temps jusqu'à
maintenant environ trois semaines chacun
aille au professeur dubois soldats
professionnels
omni reds reviendraient devez vous faire
connaître a battu 23 et louis tchèque en
stage dans quelles circonstances avez
vous été abattu j'étais en train de
survoler hanoi jeu bombardaient la ville
elle a avoué
[Musique]
piette le directeur par un missile air
air
mon avion à piquer tout droit tu as été
un j'essayais de faire fonctionner siège
éjectable
ça a brisé mes deux bras et mes jambes
je suis ton grâce à la rrq rachid
hendrick verreault specter elle est
rattrapée par des noms vietnamien qui
m'ont conduit à l'hôpital astro way home
on stars je suis presque morts ici
docteur jean perret mon bras avec mes
bras et d'autres docteurs autocars et ma
jambe avec ssd wazen qu'elle joue au
tessin ifat au 25 octobre noir est
présent maintenant vous êtes prisonnier
comment est oui traité te dire tu les
vois je traitais bien par les docteurs
et par les gens de l'api pour ie
conformant à la nourriture synamac père
c'est pas comme à paris mais ça va et
ils guettent
ouais
se pose je pense que votre famille
attendre à parler de cette rencontre que
nous avons eue top wave tout aussi je
voudrais donner le temps qui nous reste
à votre famille si vous voulez dire que
le plus choses aux gens que vous aimez à
ceux qui vous aiment
sept minutes et avoue best avec nos
systèmes audio je voulais seulement dire
à ma femme que j'irais bien moins que je
laime si j'espère la voir bientôt plus
chez les flics
c'est tout
actuel à google poids je suis sûr que
j'aurais mieux
cette année
[Musique]